drake one of the hottest music stars in
the world he placed a 1.3 million dollar
bet in bitcoin for the super bowl
everyone's talking about why drake would
be using bitcoin to bet on the super
bowl now of course he made three
separate bets he bet on the rams money
line he bet on obj having a touchdown
and he bet on obj having over 62.5
receiving yards well drake won many of
these bets and he ended up actually
getting paid but the idea of using
bitcoin is what everyone's talking about
now of course there's just really simple
explanations like banks have hours of
operations you can't actually wire large
amounts of money like 1.3 million
dollars on the weekends or in off hours
but there's also geographic arbitrage as
well
sometimes in order to actually go and
use some of these betting services they
want bitcoin instead of dollars
settlement times are faster and cost is
cheaper bitcoin is superior from a
technology format than wires or achs and
so ultimately regardless of why drake is
doing it it's just another proof point
that bitcoin is useful there's tens of
millions of people in the united states
and hundreds of millions of people
around the world that hold bitcoin they
use it as a store of value or medium of
exchange and now one of the most popular
musicians in the world not only is he
using it as a store of value he's using
it as a medium of exchange as well if
drink is talking about bitcoin posting
it online and the media is talking about
it that means more and more people are
gonna start asking themselves if bitcoin
is good for drake maybe it's good enough
for me as well
the best part about this story is not
that drake used bitcoin or not that he
had the courage and conviction to bet on
his friend it's that drake actually
ended up the weekend with more bitcoin
than he started with kudos to drake
bitcoin's inevitable bitcoin's good for
business and bitcoin is benefiting from
the biggest musician in the world
talking about it on a daily basis